How many cold opens are we going to be doing? We're doing one right now. We're doing one. Oh, okay. Let's start with the first one. And basically, the big question is, listener, how are you doing? Oh, God. How are you feeling out there, listener?
Hey, just turn this up nice and loud. Let us enter your ear hole because we're going to fill it full of. Welcome to Smartless. Yeah. Will, are you ready? Fuck. Yeah, I've been ready for fucking 20 minutes, AWOD. I mean, Will had some real technical difficulties. Sean was busy doing the Trader Joe's lobster bisque pasta. He loves that trend.
He's all over TikTok doing the lobster best pasta trend. Sean, do you do your own grocery shopping? I don't, I, yeah, sometimes I do, yeah. What was the pause for? Can you go deeper on the pausing? Yeah. Well, cause a lot of times Scotty, thank you Scotty, just made me some tea, look at that.
Yeah, no. Can he take the rest of the afternoon off? And by tea, do you mean chili? Yeah, a cup of chili. No, I do, I go to the grocery store. Scotty, do we go to the grocery store? Help me. Do we?
Yeah, sometimes we go to the grocery store. Wait a second. Yeah, we go to the grocery store. I'm sorry, can we just pause on that for one second? Can we pause on the, Scotty, do we go to the grocery store. I'm sorry, can we just pause on that for one second? Can we pause on the, Scotty, do we go to the grocery store sometimes? We do sometimes. But here's the thing.
Are you in a blackout? I only like to go when I know exactly what it is I need. And then like years ago, it's so funny you said this because last night I was talking about this. Years ago I thought it was great. Way to go JB, here we go, it's a great story. He does seem like he's really fired,
he's filled the whole gas tank ready for this one. Yeah, get into it, go ahead, go back to, take us back to years ago. Yeah, I had this idea for this app, which was, I was going to partner with all of these grocery stores, and when you walk into the grocery store, your phone recognizes your location, and then it gives you a map of that grocery store,
and you put in what exactly you're looking for, so you're not in there for an hour just looking for the one item. Some people just fill a post-it. So instead of looking at the signs above, you just look at your phone. That's right. And then somebody thought of it,
and somebody's doing it. And they're bankrupt already. Yeah. I went to, I remember one time being in Germany and seeing these stores, they had these food stores, where you go in, true story, and they'd have like set up in different areas of the store, examples of prepared meals, like a pasta,
like a chicken or whatever, and then all the way around that item, and they would switch them up every day, they'd have all the necessary ingredients that you need to buy from the store just to make that at home. Pretty good. You don't like that? Yeah, you know what, something I to make that at home. Pretty good. You don't like that?
Yeah, you know what, something I would do that. I would buy that. You know what else they do at supermarkets is they've got rows and rows and rows of ingredients that you could buy to build the thing you just tasted. This is kind of eliminating the like, oh, what do I need? I need to go and eat, no, no, no, all of it's right there.
I can't wait for this answer. I can't wait for this answer Jason by the way standing in front of his huge glass house Let me tell you something I actually really enjoy the market and when I go It's expensive because I will I'll take three hours and I'll just go aisle to aisle last time Oh, yeah, and then that's to aisle. Up and then down. And then up and then, this was 87, 88. We're talking very recent. Sometimes I need a follow card, you know, because the front one gets too thick. Lettuce and romaine lettuce and butter lettuce.
This is in the day where I'd get everything. Because I grew up in a house that was very, very sort of, quote, healthy, you know, so there wasn't any garbage in the day where I'd get everything. Because I grew up in a house that was very, very, sort of, quote, healthy, so there wasn't any garbage in the house, and so once I moved out, I bought all the garbage. I mean, the snacks, the sodas, the cereals. It's almost like when you get older and you're on your own, something feels good about not having to ask permission
to get eaten, whatever you want. Let's be clear, Sean, I grew out of it in about two years. And I've been taking care of my body ever since. You're, what, 62, 63 now? And you're still buying Froot Loops. No, I will have something like that on occasion. I'm trying to, now I'm trying to find balance for the first time ever.
Are you still off sugar? You were off sugar a couple weeks ago. Not entirely, but I didn't realize my favorite ice cream had 100 grams of sugar in a pint. Didn't realize that, huh? What do you think? Do you think ice cream is just unicorn farts and cream? Yeah, I didn't know they could manufacture unicorn farts.
Yeah, it's cream and sugar. Full stop. Yeah. What kind of dad joke do I have for you? This might have been, I'd love to just transition into our guest. This is a new, this is just a new segment. Wait, this one, because I don't know if,
I may have said this before. You've created your own segment here. I may have said this before, so please forgive me if I told you this one, all right. But I asked my brother to pass me the travel pamphlet this morning. Yeah. And he said, bro, sure.
the travel pamphlet this morning, and he said, bro, sure. Oh, I gotta giggle, I gotta giggle. JB really likes that one. JB really likes that one. That one makes me real happy, it settles me. It's good that it settles me because I'm really nervous about this next guest. I mean, you know, this is...
Is that why you wear a nice shirt? Yeah, exactly. I don't think you've ever seen me in a button-up on this show. Really nice. So today's guest, this is someone I've wanted to meet for a very long time. She first hit my radar, oh no wait, that's...
That's my wife. That's the last guest. It's Amanda. Hey, God, can you imagine how much shit you'd throw at me if I came this unprepared? And by the way, what a swipe to your guest. I'm wearing a nice shirt though. What a side swipe to your guest.
Oh no, here we go, here we go, here we go. Oh, that's it. What if it started exactly the same? I would have gone already. If I were your guest. Oh no, here we go, here we go, here we go. This is just unreal. I would be livid. What if it started exactly the same? I would have hung up, I would have gone already. If I were your guest, I would have walked. We've got a real special treat today, Dash, I think. Can't wait to meet her. This is someone who I've been watching from afar,
very, very curious about. She is stalking. Stalking. She's a true chameleon. She started acting at 15 and now barely 30. She's already won multiple Emmys, countless nominations, and seems positioned for a long and fruitful career. How did this Hebrew-speaking beauty from the Bronx
make it all the way out to Hollywood and into our hearts? Guys, let's find out. This is Miss Julia Garner. Did I say that correctly? Did I pronounce that right? You threw me with I can't wait to meet her. Oh, right? A real crafty like that.
We can unblock the camera now, my sweet love. Yeah. Oh, there you are. Hi. Hi, Julia. Oh, you look just like on the TV shows. Oh my God. It's so nice to meet you, Jason.
You too. I've heard so much about you. Wait, no Southern accent? No Southern accent. So that was just a put on from the... So that our listener knows, Julia starred in, was arguably the best part of Ozark for the entire... You're right.
For years and years, and that's how you and JB met, I presume, was on Ozark, the award-winning show brought to you by our very own JB and starring the wonderful Julia Garner. Julia, welcome to Smarless. And Jason. Jason, starring Jason. Brought to you by our friend Ted Sarandos. That's who brought it to us. Oh my God.
Huck her up. Yeah. I love you, Teddy. Teddy, you're the best. Gross. Disgusting. Go ahead. You know what, though, Julia? First of all, so nice to meet you, Teddy. Teddy, you're the best. Gross. Love you, Nina. You know what though, Julia? First of all, it's so nice to meet you.
So nice to meet you. This is really cool. Jason was joking because I know every interview you've ever given over the many, many years of Ozark was about that accent, but I was truly blown away. Because I had never seen you before, because I'm an idiot. A lot of people.
My first exposure to you was Ozark. And then when I saw you on your first talk show, I was like I had never seen you before so because I'm an idiot and my first exposure my first exposure to you was Ozark and then when I saw you on your first talk show I was like oh wait what like it was it was so believable you were completely do you love playing characters like that thing he's he's really blown away by the concept of it it's so fun right Sean? When you pretend to be someone else, is it neat? Yeah. Yeah, I guess. I mean... He thought Ozark was a documentary, sorry. He just... Jason just brought a whole film crew to the last Ozarks.
Disturbed you and your brothers? Just did like, Werner Herzog style, basically. I don't think I ever asked you, was it... It would have been fun for me I would be fun one day to play to play and do some big southern action. Yeah Why don't you do it like was it fun to do that? Hang on keep going The truck yeah
Is it fun to play to use the accent all the time? Did I use it, like, off camera when we weren't working together? No, no, no. No, no, no. When you were doing it, when you were playing the Ruth Langmore gal there. Was it a, was it a, was it work or did you enjoy actually doing that? Because you have to be conscious of it. It was both, but I feel like if you want anything
to be good, it takes a lot of work. Yeah, yeah. And also just think. I'm writing this down as you're talking. Yeah, but also it's like, also if you want, you know, I'm always constantly like chasing that flow state, so, and that takes a lot of work in a way. The flow state is. To just kind of get there. What and that takes a lot of work in a way.
To just kind of get there. What is that? That is after work. Like when you're acting. Right. Well I don't know the terms. Remember when you directed me? Yeah, yeah, but the flow, but the flow happens,
does the flow happen after massive preparation one can reach a flow state because you've properly prepared? Question? Yes. So I like prepare, I prepare, prepare, and then once I, you know, get to your set, I just throw it all away.
Yeah. You don't have to think about it. Yeah. I don't think about it. He doesn't take you out of that flow state when you see his face. It doesn't like go like... No, you know what? I love working with Jason because he kind of, I love working with Jason because he relaxes everybody. Like he makes it fun. Because sometimes when,
especially when I was like a new actor, I would always get super tense and it felt like almost like life or death and then Jason would do something ridiculous to kind of ease it. And I loved it and I think that's so important in my opinion. I love it. You are the best. You really are.
I say this to everybody, truly. Yeah. Julie, I love that. Me too. Never been directed by him. The... Jen Sarandos is the best. Jen Sarandos is also the best.
Yeah. Let me just say that. Yeah. No, no, no. But Jay, why don't you, you never ever have, by the way, neither of you, Will, you don't either never show any signs of anxiety while me and Julia are walking around with like we're nervous about showing up and doing a good job. You should look at my bowel movements. Would you?
God, can we have one episode where we don't talk Yeah. Yeah. This is, what are you talking about? Sean, you're very, you're not. No, I mean, I get nervous, like you just said, Julia, about right before you start, and is the character that I worked on, any gonna be any good, and blah, blah, blah, you know? And then once you get, but I just don't feel that from you guys, right?
Well, you know, sort of in that vein, Julia, so you do, you're gonna do Ozark. Obviously you meet Mr. Bateman. Thank you. As he makes you, I heard that Well, you know, sort of in that vein, Julia, so you're gonna do Ozark. Obviously you meet Mr. Bateman as he makes you, I heard that he made you call him. And so you go through the process of getting that gig and you show up day one on set and you know that you're playing this Southern character. Were you nervous at all about taking that first swing,
that first take of that first scene? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Or had you guys prepped enough and he knew? No, I was so nervous because also, first of all, I thought that I wasn't gonna get Ozark when I auditioned for it. Well, his face just sagged, so he's always got a mean look on his face.
No, it wasn't even, I actually felt, the first audition, this is him smiling, right? Look at his nose getting up, he's like got a meat hook on his face. I actually felt, the first audition, look at his nose getting up, he's like, mm-hmm. He thinks he's smiling. He has to turn his whole head up, smiling. Yeah, he's just like, look at him, it's like, I can see a booger right there. No, but it was kind of crazy because the first audition,
I thought, you know, it was just like a tiny, tiny casting room in New York, paper thin walls, and I'm like hearing the other actors read the lines and I'm like, oh my God. That's the worst. Yeah, and I'm like, wow, she killed it. And they're like, that was amazing, that was fantastic. And then I had to go in next and I did it once. And I remember calling my mother and I was like, I'm not, I don't think I'm, I'm just
going to move on. And then I want to say like 10 days later, there was a callback and Jason was in that callback and I remember the, I remember he- Slower. He kept it. No, I'm trying. No, I'm just- Sean. I remember he... Slower. I'm trying to make up a story that...
He gave very good, he gave amazing, like really interesting direction, but also he was very sweet. And then he started talking about like local TV at the end of the audition. Local news. You were saying, what are you going to do later? I was like, I don't know. Watch some TV. And he's like, what are you going to watch? Local news. That was... That is funny.
That's literally the first thing. And then I was like, that guy's an oddball, but I like him. And I was like, but also how does he know that I kind of like love secretly local news too? He saw me, like immediately. Yes, yes. Did I say any, I didn't, we didn't, I didn't say hey high five you got the job in the room, did I? No, no and Chris was in the room and I just remember feeling like still unsure.
But I do remember with the first, it was like a mock scene. It wasn't even in the script. But I do remember seeing- Did I read with you? Yeah, you read with me. I did. And I remember the first scene that I saw, I was like, this dialogue's either gonna work
if this person talks really fast or really slow. There was no in between. That was always very clear in the dialogue, I feel like. And you went with the fast. Depending on her mood. Yeah. And then what about the accent? Was that something that Alexa Fogle,
sort of our casting director, did she give you a sort of a hint, a tip on that? Like you should speak, or is that just something you did on your own? No, by the way, we love Alexa Fogle. Shout out to Alexa Fogle. Shout out to Alexa Fogle. Yes, like grateful for Alexa.
She loves that well, Arnett. I've known her many years. Yeah. No, it was kind of one of those things that I just assumed because it was Missouri that there was going to be an accent. Missouri. And that's also why I didn't feel like the first audition, nobody was doing that accent.
And then I couldn't remember my lines with my regular speaking voice. So I started freaking out. That's why I didn't think I was going to get the job. Oh, wow. Wow. Yeah. Did you, you know, I will say it reminded me of, did you ever know people, I knew a few actors over the year, especially like in the 90s, being in New York,
and sometimes coming out here, and you'd often over a course of years see like the same kind of people who were kind of your age up for the similar jobs, and you'd see them over and you get to know them from waiting rooms and stuff around town. Yeah. Oh my God.
That's how I had the misfortune of originally meeting Thoreau over the years was in waiting rooms. Right? There's always an actor in a waiting room. Like, yeah. But there were those, but you know those actors who would come out, I knew a couple and they thought they were being funny
and they'd come out and they'd go like, well, I got it. Like that was their bit all the time was, I got it, nobody else. And like at a certain point you're like, hey man, just stay in your lane. Stay away from me. I'm trying to get, I wanna work too.
And then cut to you walking out of the Arrested Development audition and everyone and all the executives following you out saying, all right, we got it, we got our guy, as you guys all walked past the remaining guys that were supposed to go in and audition for your part. Why did they do that? Which, if you remember, JB, at the time,
I said to Mitch, I said, hey, let's keep it down. It was part of the story because one of the people was out there in the room who didn't get it and I felt I knew what that feeling was. Yeah. Well, we can say who knew what that feeling was. Yeah. Well, we can say who that is, because he did just fine. Rainn Wilson went on to get the office
a couple weeks later. Yeah, he would have beat me at that gig. So like, you know what I mean? Let's just be clear about that. Anyway, so that kind of like actor politics is always weird. Well, it's funny, and I feel like that's slowly disappearing. Like, I feel like I was kind of the last,
the very, very last of, like there's so many actors that are working today that I've met in audition rooms when I was like 16, 17 years old. And then like there would be like a hangout after, like, oh yeah, do you like want to hang out? Yeah, like it was just like a little more, there was like, it's spontaneous a little more now.
It's just, yeah. But you were also, but you're also, you were a great hanger outer on Ozark, right? You guys, you always went out. I don't even know what that means. Well, but because you always, I would always hear the next morning at work, like you guys would all talk about the night you guys had out,
you'd go out with all the other actors and you guys would all have a lot of fun I was also 22 when I started a real life down there You know you JB granddad went home put on the comfy socks and PJs and watch Rachel Maddow and learn my lines and went to bed Still doing the same thing today Over no regrets. What have you haven't missed anything. It's all going to be over. No regrets. What have you done? Nothing!
I've got one tooth left in my mouth. I've had no life experiences. But I'm thin! Yes! We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. Well, get off, I was like really, you know, I'm sure after this, I could talk about it forever.
I love the show. No, shut up, you have not seen it. I love seeing every episode. The, was there anything, because it was like, at times it was really physical. And I remember Jason telling me that I was like, did you really do all that? He's like, no, that was a stunt double
where he gets punched in the face, thrown on the floor, kicked across the like, did you really do all that? He's like, no, that was a stunt double where he gets punched in the face, thrown on the floor, kicked across the room. Did you have anything like that? Did you ever get hurt? Yeah, I mean, yeah. Yeah, but I'm also like, I'm like, you know. She's a little flower. Yeah, but I also don't sometimes carry myself like one.
So that's how I get hurt. Oh, okay, okay. Julia, have you learned how to- Yes, I'm like, oh yeah, I'll be fine. I'll be fine. Have you learned how to drive since the show? You didn't know how to drive? This woman, I mean, you asked her to just drive 10 feet.
Just hit the mark. You just gave me a drive 10 feet. I'm going to learn how to drive. I promise. We're going to put sandbags in front of the wheel. And you're going to be the first person that I'm going to call. As soon as I learn how to drive.
I'm not getting in the car. I will not get in the car to you. I think I'll be a great, I think. At least a year under your belt. Wait, Julie, do you drive now or you still don't drive? No, because I just, I've been. Where do you live? Los Angeles. Yeah.
Okay, well, I don't, I. You honestly still don't drive? No, and then whenever I'm in the process of learning how to drive, then I have to leave town. For real, like it's like always like that. So as soon as like learning how to drive, then I have to leave town. For real, it's always like that. So as soon as I want to work, I just try to learn how to drive and then I'll. So how do you get around?
You Uber all the time or does Mark drive you around? Both. Friends. You know what the kids say today? Yeah, what the kids say, I'm like a passenger princess. That's what the kids say today. Totally. By the way, even if I learn how to drive, I still love to be driven.
I'm not going to lie. Like, I love it. Call me if you ever need a ride. I like to drive. All right, wait. Wait a minute, Julie. Wait, I want to stay on this driving thing just for just two seconds. Okay, okay, Sean.
So, wait, you have your friends drive you or Mark is your boyfriend or husband? I can ask you 70 million questions about this. Wait. And have you ever waymode? So, wait, you have your friends drive you, or I'm guessing Mark is your boyfriend or husband? Yeah, my husband. I could ask you 17 million questions about this. And have you ever waymode? Is that the thing that's a self-driving car? That scares me. I don't like that. I've done that before with my friend,
because he also doesn't drive, because he's from the UK, and that scares me. That's crazy. Sean's a big advocate. Well, no, I mean, I think it's where the future is gonna I think ultimately like 20 Is that where we're going? Prognosticator yeah, do you think AI is gonna have an impact? Wait, what's AI? What's gonna be popular computers? What else?
I think food's really gonna catch on any more hot takes I think food's really gonna catch on. Any more hot takes? Julia, I've got a question for you. Sean, quiet please. Yes, Dave. So you booked Martha Marcy Mae Marlene. Yeah. Hold for applause.
At 16, was this the first time that you really felt acting was a viable career path, Julia? Julia, please answer the question. Please answer the question. Please answer the question. It was still like a test because I was so young. I was 16. So I was still in- That was like the first biggie, right? Yeah, that was the first job.
And I didn't even really know because this was 2010. And so Sundance was not what it is today. It wasn't like it was still felt kind of indie in that way. There was, I think like swag bag was like a thing for like two, it was like, it was just new. So it wasn't commercialized in a way. So I didn't really know what that, anything was. So it felt more like a test, I guess, in a way. But I just really loved it. I just
loved meeting people. And then Phil kind of took off and you started to get some notoriety and the phone started ringing just a little bit and like, was that kind of exciting? Notoriety? Was it bad news? What happened? Did you do something bad? Could you kind of see the future a little bit? Did you have the courage to kind of dream a little bit there or was it still a little bit? Did you have the courage to kind of dream a little bit there or was it still a little distant? Well, I've always been a big dreamer, but I never thought that my life would end up
like this. I never thought that this was... I always loved movies. I grew up watching Turner Classic movies and I always loved, loved films, but there was still something that felt very far, even though I grew up in New York and I grew up around actors and going to the theater, but there's something that felt very far because it wasn't, I didn't know it was like a real profession. Like, it didn't feel real. Right, so then even as sort of some momentum
started to gain there, so you're 16, you're approaching the end of what would be the high school years and the possibility to maybe go to college and study another career. So since you weren't really committed to, you weren't allowing yourself to feel super positive about a career in the business, were you keeping your other irons hot
as far as other occupations, other industries? No, because I was so bad at everything else. And I seemed. She didn't, you were all in. You didn't even go to college? No, and I was like, oh well, I'm getting a good response with this, so I must be okay with it,
because I'm so bad at everything else. You know what's funny about that is that we, that's a common, that answer comes up for a lot and it goes for the three of us too, right? And what I find, I'm sort of coming to the conclusion that actors are just a bunch of people who are bad at everything else. Yeah.
All right, it's true. Like let's pretend, let's get a job where we can pretend to be good at stuff. Yeah, it's kind of true. Yeah, that's so true. I didn't do, I don't do well when I feel like there's like, has to be rules in a way. Like I don't, I, you know, I like-
That there's a right way to do something and a wrong way to do something. Yeah, like I like running, I like the feeling of like running around and kind of being free, as corny as that sounds, but yeah. Right, right, right, right. Sounds like you're advocating for anarchy. Yeah, yeah.
No, she is. She's a rule breaker. Yeah, I'm a rule breaker. I didn't know about this. I'm not against it. Tell me about, what is this David Chase thing that Wikipedia is talking about here? Oh, so there's actually, speaking of, so that was my second movie. This is Not Fade Away is Not Fade Away.
Not Fade Away. And this is a crazy story. So my first time going to LA, I was, I just turned 17. It was like a month after I turned 17. And I only remember this because it was like in March and all the purple trees. I'd never seen anything like that.
Jackarandas. Jackarandas, yeah. Yeah. Jackarandas. Yeah, and I remember being Jackaranda. like in March and all the purple trees. I'd never seen anything like that in New York. Yeah. And I remember being, check it mom doll. Were you alone at 17 or did you come out with mom? No, I came out with mom and my acting coach. Oh yeah? You know, and.
Did you stay at the Oakwoods? Yeah. You did? Did you really? Nearby, yeah. And we didn't know where anything was. in the Oakwoods? Yeah. You did? Did you really? Nearby, yeah. Oh, I did. And we didn't know where anything was. This was like, GPS was new, so it was like recalculating.
It was like all the time. It was so crazy. Sounds like mom was as gifted as you are behind the wheel. Yeah, basically. Yes, recalculating, exactly. But it was one of those things that I had crazy callbacks, auditions every single day while I was doing that one day of shoot for the David Chase project
that he basically wrote that part for me because I auditioned for a different part. And I didn't get James Gadolfini's daughter, so he wrote, he was like, I wrote a part for you, and it was like in this dream sequence. So that was my first time in LA. And on the plane, I got the worst eye infection on my way there.
I had green pus coming out of my eye, like green goo. It was terrible. And I had all these auditions booked, all these callbacks. Like sometimes, these callbacks, I was looking at them, I'm like, where are these meetings now? Like, I'm like, these meetings were crazy. And I had- Oh, you poor thing, you must have been just a nervous wreck
that you were gonna show up with this pink eye. So this callback, this callback that I had, so there was all these callbacks and auditions and meetings with this like, and it wasn't contagious. So I went to a doctor and they're like, yeah, you're fine, but it just looks, it's literally an eye sore. And I got this phone call, well, I had a chemistry read with claredanes.
So I had to like go in with an eye infection with claredanes, and I had to apologize, basically explain my eye, which was horrific. Don't look at this one, look at this one. Yeah. That so-called eye. And then... Well, that is great.
And then in the middle of all these meetings, going back and forth, didn't know where I was going, never been to LA, I got a call from my manager all these meetings going back and forth, didn't know where I was going, never been to LA. I got a call from my manager and a few weeks before I went out, in New York I went on this audition for an untitled Paul Thomas Anderson film. Is there a phone ringing? I can't... No, you made a movie. I don't know what's going on. I didn't see that one.
Yeah. By the way, it would be a great title for a Paul Thomas Anderson film. Is there a phone ringing? Exactly. No, so it was an untitled Paul Thomas Anderson film. I was 16 and they called in. They're like, he wants to meet with you. So I had that. and they called in, they're like, he wants to meet with you. So I had that, and then it turned out to be for the master.
Oh wow, I love that. Yeah, and, but I had this eye infection. Like I had this crazy chemistry read. And yeah, but that was my first time in LA. And then also who I met that week was Fred Roos. I was 17 years old. It was like one of, you know, he was the producer of The Godfather. But then by then I met him,
it was like a Friday in my eye, like calm down. But during that time I also did not fade away, just to give you, you know, I'm giving you the bullet points. What were you meeting with Fred Roos about? Just a general meeting, I guess, I don't know. It was kind of- Did he make you an offer you couldn't refuse? Hell no!
No, I just met with him. Okay, I just thought maybe, yeah. So jump from that to... Yeah, but that was my first time in LA. Like crazy trip. So if you will, make a big huge leap now from your sort of nascent stage there, and now you've just won your first Emmy
of three consecutive Emmys, by the way. Unbelievable. What did that feel? So you've just won an Emmy. What a streak! What a streak! Been beaten three years in a row! What was that like?
Personally and professionally, was there a big sea change or was it sort of a gradual thing? Or, sorry, I'm recalling that. Here's the question. Did the next day after winning an Emmy feel like you thought it would when you allowed yourself to dream back when you were a little kid? Very good, very good.
Well, first of all, Jason, I just want to say like the, it's, you know, it was such a dream working with you this whole time, or that whole time of just the, and what I mean is like the process, it really, the next day, it was not depressing, it was not depressing, but it made you look at how important the process is and the experience rather than the result in a way.
And it's a token in a way. It's an amazing token and it's like an opportunity for things, but then after the opportunity, you're looking for a new process in a way. Yeah, because you kind of feel like there's nothing really changed. It's just the next day. Well, the dwarf in Russia and all that stuff
is all in the anticipation. It's not in the getting of the thing, which is true. Yeah, and also your problems, like you'll have 30 seconds up there, and it's great, and then you get off the stage and then you're like the next day your problems are, personally your problems are still following you. It doesn't change anything.
That's why I've never won an Emmy. That's why. You just keep returning. Yeah, no, I want to take myself out of the running. It's not going to change anything. Yeah, I know you mean it. But it's funny, I think what it resulted to was after that, I was, it made me feel not confident
in a complete different way, in a sense. Because what it does, well, when you have a win after win after win after win, you kind of put this pressure or you feel like people are having this expectation on you. But during the strike, I went to clown school, because I didn't know what else to do with my time. And I went to France, and the thing that the teacher, Philippe Golié, who's amazing, he kept on saying, you know the...
Screw that son of a bitch. I'll show this guy a thing or two about being a clown. Oh, you like French? Come to Italy. Sorry, this is a running joke. He's got a real loud mouth. He's a handful in the back of the ear. And he's got a real touchy incentive about other Europeans. Yes, exactly.
But he kept on saying the failure is the friend of the clown, which I love. Failure is the friend of the clown. I like that. And you can't have great art if you don't have some sort of like, you know, humility in a way. Please tell me what goes on in clown school. A lot of things. Face painting.
But I mean like you hear that. Are you guys kind of juggling a lot of different things? Yeah. Nice Will, another nice one. Well actually I didn't, you know I didn't, I did get a clown certificate so you are talking to a certified clown. Was it an oversized shoe or?
Or just a red nose. Did it pull me? It was a red nose and he assigned me, he took one look at me and he was like, you are the witch. He assigned me to be a witch. I don't know, I maybe give him like witch energy. The witch with one cigarette.
Wait, but I mean, do you do like, cause I hear it and I'm an idiot, so I hear, I went to clown school and I do everything that Jason and Will are joking about. Like I think about like, oh, well you put the paint, is it that, you paint your face and you put on white? No, no, it's. It's old school like European clown.
Yeah, it's old school, yeah. It's kind of depressing. Oh really? Yeah, it's like he puts you on stage and then you go behind a curtain and then they cue the music and you walk around like in a clown circle and then you just, and then you go behind a curtain and then they cue the music and you walk around like in a clown circle and then you just, and then the music stops and you just have to do whatever comes to your mind
and make people laugh. And if you don't make people laugh, he kicks you off the stage. Oh my God, wow. So you have to really kind of just completely almost humiliate yourself. Just basically pull your pants down metaphorically, right? And just be a fool.
Be a fool. So I also, I just felt this, the first two days, I was like, what the fuck am I doing? Why did I do this? What is wrong with me? I'm not even a Paris, I'm in this town, which by the way, the town that I was staying in, I was like, why is this energy so crazy?
And there's the biggest mental asylum in France the town that I was staying in, I was like, sign me up for like the weirdest experience and I'm like all up for that. But yeah, no, it was an amazing, it was a 10 out of 10 experience, genuinely, it was amazing. How about that? Yeah, that's really cool. So has it adjusted your acting at all?
Did it sort of incorporate this fearlessness of humiliation? Although you were always brave about, you never worried about making yourself look foolish or ugly or flawed or something like that. No, not ugly. Well, no, and I think for me it was more that I just needed to, I have to constantly make myself feel uncomfortable.
And that's gonna make me feel comfortable as an artist. Like, if I feel any sort of comfortability, I don't, like, then something's deeply wrong. Yeah, I totally get it. And also, I don't like... You totally get it. You're comfortable beyond me. Are you serious? No, no, I know, the being uncomfortable.
You walk around in cashier slippers starting at 10.30 a.m. You and one other person living in a 15,000 square foot house. Shut the hell up, Sean. Go ahead, Cass. I'm uncomfortable. She's talking about discomfort as a fucking artist. Jesus Christ. I'm not talking, listen, don't give me, I love my sweaters, but I just. There's our bumper sticker. We'll be right back.
All right, back to the show. Julia, now, you're surrounded by musicals that are not really your thing. I mean, I'm not saying that you're not, Right back. Alright, back to the show. Julia, now you're surrounded by musical instruments, and I've been wanting to ask since, are these yours? No, these are my husband's. Okay. We're setting up a studio here.
She's married to a rock star, you stupid dick. Okay, nobody's supposed to know. No, I can't play anything. You're supposed to study up. What did you Google out during this interview? I didn't know it was... Is he a singer? I don't know who he... Forgive me.
He's Mark Foster, Foster the People. Oh, wonderful. I didn't know that. No, that's a band. This is a fantastic band. That's great. Wait, can I jump ahead? I mean, I'll let Jay drive it in a second,
but were you, I just remembered, were you supposed to play Madonna at some point? Is that gonna still happen? Yeah, I mean, that's supposed to still happen, but. That's wild. Yeah. What do you think, I mean, how did that come about? And like, were you ever a fan and all that?
Oh my God, I was such a fan of Madonna's. I grew up listening to Madonna. It just came about, I knew that they were doing a project, making a movie about it, and then I went out to audition. That was also another thing that I kind of just wanted to see if I could do it. Because, you know, I wasn't a trained dancer, and I had to like learn how to dance and then dance in front of her.
And convince her that I can dance, basically. And sing. And sing with her. Wow. Stressful. Yeah. I mean, was... so then how was that? Did it go well? Did she give you a bunch of notes?
Or was she just like, oh my God, you're amazing, do this, do that? Well, you know, I kind of just like thought like, okay, what would Madonna do? Which is like, convince you that she deserved, you know, to be in this room. Right. And, you know. You owned it.
And I owned it. And I was kind of like, you can take it or leave it, but if you leave it, if I leave, then that's on you. You know what I mean? And it's like, if you take it, great. That kind of like mentality. Yeah, you just build that sexy indifference. And work the room, literally work the room.
So what happened with that? What happened with that? Still sort of brewing. Still brewing. It's a long gestating, you know, good meals take a long time. But I also feel like anything that's great also too, I notice if you hear stories,
like I feel like it takes a long time. Or it's, you know, it's either long or short. But meanwhile, meanwhile, you've snuck in a couple of fantastic jobs. Fantastic Four, anyone? Oh yes. July 25th. That's gonna be huge.
Yeah, I mean, what was that process like? I imagine there was a lot of effects. You had to work with that pain in the ass Pedro Pascal. I don't know how you get through that. How do you get through something like that? He's real chatty. It's so, I love him. You know, it's so funny,
because I met Pedro when I was 18. And everybody now is on this Pedro craze, which I'm so happy about, but I've... Not us. We're not fans, we're not fans. But I, you know, I've met him, and I always thought, you know, he was just so talented, and it was always a matter of time with him, I felt. And so, but what about, so like green screens
and special effects and all that, like that's a big spicy meatball, that thing. You've got costumes and like future stuff. What was that like? Well, no, I didn't have any costumes because they, I was just like with. Because you're a silver surfer. Yeah, so I was just like.
Oh wait, you're the silver surfer? Yeah, so I was like. Take it easy, Sean. Yeah, so I was just like... Oh wait, you're the silver surfer? Yeah, so I was like... Take it easy, Sean. Yeah, so it was... There comes Scottie. Scottie's gonna slide in on a chair like Weekend Update. Hey, question! No, I used to love this.
When I was a kid, I used to watch it all the time. Yeah, so just like I'm chrome and silver. Yeah, it's so cool. So does that mean you had to wear a green bodysuit with little markers on it for visual effects? I had the helmet with the giant GoPro-type camera and the wires. And it was crazy. And the first day on set, my first day on set was wild because, well, I finished Weapons,
which is another thing. No, Weapons, let's not jump to the Josh Brolin vehicle coming out August 8th called Weapons. Yeah, by the way. So I filmed that like, I want to say like three weeks before, so like, but my first day on Fantastic, I... That's Fantastic Four, yeah. Fantastic Four, my first step, yes. Yes, that's Fantastic Four.
I had to do this, like all these lines in the middle of, it's supposed to be like Times Square, and it was 30 feet in the air. JB, you did a bunch of lines in the middle of Times Square, right, like 94? Sure did, yeah. The New Year's celebration is always classic. That's what it was.
But it was crazy because I was doing, it was my first day on set and I was doing a scene 30 feet in the air with an earpiece and a microphone, talking to 500 extras. And number two was at Marvel, from Marvel, was on set. So I was like, that was my first day. But after that I felt like I have no reason to be nervous, I think, if I can do a scene 33 in the air. You have a robust promotion schedule coming up.
You gonna travel the world for that? Yeah, so it's, I mean, I feel like with that, they were so, the four, the fantastic four, the cast, they were so nice and I kind of felt like a really nice dinner guest in a way. So they were really great hosts. So I'll come in and out to their dinners, but I'm not going to...
And I'll be a good dinner guest, but I'm not going to be the dinner guest. You'll be number five over there. You'll hit your cities. Exactly. Alright, so then that comes out July 25th and you got Weapons with Josh Brolin, August 8th. Jeez, man. Exactly. All right. So then that so then that comes out July 25th and you got weapons with Josh Brolin August 8 He's me. Tell what's what's weapons about first of all Brolin? I mean, yeah, bro
Now you think Pedro Pascal's a pain in the ass. Yeah, bro I know I just I work with all the bus men Jason Pedro Josh Well, you know how to slay the dragons. Yeah What is that one about? It's so crazy. It's kind of like a multi-story, intertwined spider web,
but it's like a horror, magnolia kind of vibe. I don't even know how to explain it. I'm going to explain it. When all but one child from the same class mysteriously vanished on the same night at exactly the same time, a community is left questioning who or what is behind their disappearance.
Huh. Well there it is. And I play a teacher. I'm in. I'm in. I like you and I like the Brolin fella. I think he's going to go far. Julie, what do you do for fun?
Yeah, work, work, work, work, work. What do you do when you don't work. Julie, what do you do for fun? What do you do for fun? Yeah, work, work, work, work, work. What do you do when you don't work? Yeah, what do you do when you don't work? You sound like you work a lot, which is great, bravo. You know, it's great. Great work, Epic! But what do you do when you're just chilling? You're not driving, so we know that.
Yeah. Are you...? What are the hobbies? I'm going to sound so bad in this interview. Oh my God. She just skateboards around LA. What's the hobby? Yeah.
I'm trying to figure that out. You have zero hobby right now. But when you're down, like you're in LA, you're down, you've got down time. Well the problem is is that when I'm not working, I love watching movies, but then even then, it still feels like I'm reminded that it still worked. Like what are you gonna do the rest of today?
You're not going to set today? Well, I have an ADR after this today. And then I am leaving on Thursday to Vancouver for five and a half months. Oh my God. Wow. So then you're gonna pack, you'll pack tomorrow. Yeah, yeah.
Right. Okay. So I'm always going to pack, you'll pack tomorrow. Yeah, yeah. Right, okay. It's not always working. That's great. What about, what are you watching right now on television? Aside from the movies. Like, will you just put on an old movie wherever it is? Yeah, well, and then, or I'll watch new stuff, or I'll watch things that, you know,
that I know that I should watch, that I haven't watched yet. Like Below Deck Mediterranean? Yeah, by the way, I never got into that. I'm maybe one of the few. But now I just, I'm gonna finish watching the Paul Rubin doc. It's really good. Oh yeah, I finished it. It's really good, it's interesting.
It's so good. Did you see the Osama Bin Laden doc? I started watching it and I wanted to binge watch it, so I stopped. But it looks, it's interesting. It's so good. Did you see the Osama Bin Laden dog? I started watching it and I wanted to binge watch it, so I stopped, but it looks, it's amazing. Now what about, talk to me about fashion and modeling, I'm sure that's a passion for you, but also fun. Well, I mean, I kind of. Sorry, not for you, this is for our guest,
this is for our guest, Julia. Yeah, yeah. Is that kind of a hobby? I mean, you don't look at it as, you're not doing that to make a living because you make plenty as an actor. I'd imagine that it's kind of fun to be asked to do these things.
Well, I actually, like, there was a very long time where I actually made better money doing that than my acting. Really? Yeah, a lot of that came from that. Wow. So it's like a half, it's like a, I'm like, I'm, you know, I have two jobs, I guess. I don't know, but yeah.
And so do you love, you love all the dress up and the traveling and the... I don't love the traveling, but I, as you know, I do love, I've always loved fashion as a kid, because I always found it like a form of expression, in a way. You've got a big billboard in New York, what was it for that I've just seen recently?
It was Gucci. Gucci? That was amazing, because I got to shoot with Stephen Mizell again, and he shot my first cover when I was like 21. Wow. Wow. Yeah. That's cool.
I think it was like a year before it did Ozark. The first Ozark. Yeah. Oh my God. So long ago. That's really fucking cool. Yeah. Very, very cool.
Sean, you ever done a cover? Yeah. This year or no? I mean... Sorry. We need to be more specific. Yeah, just give me the year. I think you could do a cover.
I think you can do a cover, yeah, why not? GQ, whatever. Well, Julia, when you get back in five and a half months, maybe we can say hi again. I know, I know, and I get like, I always, you know, I miss working with you. That's the thing that I want to do the most, is just, you know, work with you. That's the thing that I want to do the most, is just work with you again.
Boy, she closed her eyes when she said that. You know what I mean? It's a tell. No, I didn't. A little bit of a tell. Well, a little bit. Tell us one thing that we don't know about Jason that you experienced on.
That was kind of fun, but also revealing and maybe embarrassing. She can't think of it. No, I can't. It's so not, Jason's probably the most, he paid me to say all of this, by the way. No, I can't. It's so not, Jason's probably the most, he paid me to say all of this by the way. No, I'm kidding. No, Jason is the most nurturing director
I've ever worked with. He's, there's this sense of safety that... That's our time. I think we just did it. You know what though, if I ever had the chance to direct Will or Sean, I'd be a fucking monster with them. Yeah, what do you think? You already have.
Shut up over there, Will. You fucking directed... And we got into an argument the first time you directed Arrested Development. Yeah, because he came in all fucking pouty because... Who was it? Who lost the election? Kerry? Kerry, yeah. John who lost the election? Kerry? Kerry, yeah.
John Kerry lost the election and old Canadian Will walks on to say all pouty about our country. Hey man, I was wearing yellow leotards and I was in a fucking banana suit, that's a true story. I had to pick you up. And Jason and I, and he picked me up with a crane and we got in an argument. Dropped you in the bay, yeah.
And I'm in a fucking banana suit and we're arguing outside, he's like, just do the fucking scene, I'm like, fucking banana suit and we're arguing outside. He's like, just do the fucking scene. I'm like, hey, fuck you. Yeah. Oh, I love it. Was that the last time you worked with him? That was it.
As a director. Jason, as an actor and Jason directing? He's pursued me so much. I just can't make a deal. I can't, yeah, I can't make a deal. You could've closed the deal. One time we worked together as an actor, it was the smartless doc, right?
But that wasn't really acting. No, that wasn't acting. That was the last time we did anything, yeah. I mean, I see you every goddamn day now doing this. I'm always acting like I like you. And then Sean. This was so funny how this happened, because I remember you were doing Ozark
when you started this podcast. And I remember you were like, yeah, I'm just doing something silly. It's like I'm just doing it with my friends. We're just, you know, for shits and gigs. And cut to. It's a monster. Thank you listeners.
Nice people. I get to meet my heroes like Julia Garner. You're everything I hoped you would be, Julia. They say don't meet your heroes and you were just such a delight. Just such a delight. Love to meet you in person one day. When you get back from your movie, please look me up.
I'll try, I'll find you. Yes, please do. Love you, love to your mother, love to Mark. Have a great shoot. And we're gonna see Fantastic Four. We're gonna see see the weapons. July what? July what?
July 25th. July 25th. August 8th. August 8th, weapons. Yeah, and then look for the Altra she's about to, is that what you're about to go do? Yes, yep. That's going to be on Netflix.
Sam Banfield, playing his wife, girlfriend? Caroline Ellison. Yeah. Wow. Very, very good wife, girlfriend? Caroline Ellison. Wow. Very, very good. That's exciting. Impressive. You're an impressive person. Congrats on everything, Julia.
Very thrilled for you. Happy for you. Love you. Go kill it. Thank you. Hit me when you're back. Yes, I will. Thank you guys so much.
Bye, Julia. Thank you. Bye, Julia. Bye. Oh my God, Jason. Right? By the way, thank you. Bye Julia. Bye. Oh my God, Jason. Right? By the way, you must genuinely feel a sense of pride,
having watched her grow from being sort of a young actor, like a young kid. She was 22. Yeah, she starts on the show, a show that you helped create and brought to life and directed and were the star of, and then she was not only amazing in it, but was recognized and had all the success
and has now had a huge career, and in part by all the great work she did on a show that you were instrumental in. You must feel a great sense of pride in that. Yes, but just barely. I take nothing away from her. I mean, she was like- You're not taking credit. Yeah, no, but I mean, take nothing away from her. She was like
Yeah, no, but I mean she I remember very very quickly We made a sort of a decision to really make that character Really drive a lot of story because she was so so good and the audience was going crazy for her and yeah it was really credit to Chris Mundy and the whole writing staff that kind of changed a lot of storylines to really utilize what a great talent she was. Yeah, she's, yeah, and a delightful person.
Like I'd never met her before. Oh my God, yeah. It's so, so sweet. My God. So sweet. Exact opposite of the monster, you know, Ruth was. Although, you know, she did play the character with a lot of vulnerability, but like she was really capable of just monster, Ruth, although she did play the character with a lot of vulnerability, but she was really capable of just being vicious.
You love to hate her. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Love the character, I mean. But what a sweetheart, I'm so glad she's doing really well, and happy home life, happy work life, yeah. How about you, yeah, I always find it interesting when a lot of actors I know are married to musicians, you know? Like, it's a good combo.
You're married to one. Yes, I am married to one. He makes music, yeah. And Will, you do some modeling. I'm married to my work, yeah, as a model. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, what's your next, your next campaign for, Will?
My next campaign is for laxative. Okay. And I've moved into a different category at this stage of my life. Something for the seniors? Yeah, which I think, and now we live in this world, and so anyway, so it's like... So those photo shoots gotta be shorter then, no? When the poster is just, I give a shit, a lot, You know? And it's going pretty well. Yeah, it sounds like it's going smooth. Yeah.
Hey, yeah. I got new glasses. Okay. Oh boy. So you got the kind that you got. And so working bifocal backwards. That's right. Oh, well you ruined it.
No, no, no, go ahead. Oh, I don't think I ruined it. I don't think you were ahead of anybody on that. The second you. No, no, go ahead. Oh, I don't think I ruined it. I don't think you were ahead of anybody The second you said glasses, but go fuck a story about your new spec. They really are new I just got yesterday are they all right? Was it one prescription or two because the bottoms are what are they? No, it's not the bottoms are it by having to it makes them by The buys so angry By having two, it makes them... Bye, Focals! Do you not get that? Well, you said that the bye is so angry.
Because you just don't get it when it is bye! Goodbye. Goodbye. Smart. Less. Smart.ess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess.
SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry and Rob Armjarff. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.